so in this final segment today we're
going to talk about set theory just a
little bit because if you're going to
take a math class if you're going to be
exposed to math for computer science
it's useful to have at least a
glimmering of what the foundations of
math looks like how it starts and how it
gets justified and that's what set
theory does in addition we will see that
the diagonal argument that we've already
made much of plays a played a crucial
role in the development and
understanding of set theory so let's
begin with an issue that plays an
important role in set theory and in
computer science having to do with the
idea of taking a function and applying
it to itself or or having something
refer to itself and this is one of these
things that's notoriously doubtful
there's all these paradoxes about it
maybe the simplest one is when I assert
this statement is false and the question
is is it true or false well if it's true
then it's false and if it's false then
it's true and we get a kind of buzzer
it's not possible to figure out whether
this statement is true or false I think
we would deny that it was a proposition
so that's a hint that there's something
suspicious about self-references
self-application and so on on the other
hand it's worth remembering that in
computer science we take this for
granted so let's look at an example
here's a simple example of a list in a
scheme Lisp notation meaning it's a list
of three things ero one and two and the
black parens indicate that we're
thinking of it as an ordered list now
the way that I would represent a list
like that in memory typically is by
using these things that are called
consul so a consul has these two parts
the left hand part points to the value
in that location in the list so this
first consul points to 0 which is the
first element of the list the second
component of the consul points to the
next element of the list and so here you
see one pointing to the third element of
the list and there you see two and that
the mill marker indicates that's the end
of the list so that's a simple
representation of a list of length three
with three consoles well one of the
things that a computer science let you
do in many languages let you do is that
you can manipulate these pointers so
using the language of scheme what I can
do is do an operation called set car
where I'm taking in this case I'm
setting the second element of L that is
this consul to L and set car is saying
let's change what the element in the in
the left-hand part of this cell is this
is where the value of the second element
is let's change the value of the second
element to be L what does that mean as a
pointer manipulation it's pretty simple
I just move this pointer to point to the
beginning of the list L and now I have
an interesting situation because this
list now is a list that consists of of 0
and L and toe it's a list that has
itself as a member and it makes perfect
sense and if you sort of expand it out L
is this list that has begins with 0 and
then its second element is a list that
begins with 0 and the second element of
that list is a list that begins with 0
and so on and then the third element of
L is 2 and the third element of the
second element of L is 2 and so on it's
an interesting infinite nested structure
that's nicely represented by this finite
the circular list ok um let's look at
another example where in computer
science we actually apply things to
themselves so let's define the
composition operator and again I'm using
notation from the language scheme I want
to take two functions F and G that take
one argument and I'm going to define
their composition the way that I compose
F and G is I define a new function H of
X which is going to be the composition
of a change
the way I define H of X as I say apply G
to F could you apply F to G applied to X
and return the value H so this is a
compose as a procedure that takes two
procedures F and G and returns their
composition H okay let's practice
suppose that I compose the square
function that map's X to x squared and
the add one function that map's X to X
plus one well if I compose the square of
adding one and I apply it to three what
I'm saying is let's add one two three
and then square it and I get three plus
one squared or 16 because the and one
and then square it is the function
that's the composition of square and an
one now I can do the following I could
square this I could compose square with
itself if I take the function square it
and square that I'm really taking the
fourth power so if I apply the function
compose of square square to 3 I get 3
squared squared or 81 or 3 to the fourth
what makes perfect sense ok well now
let's define a a compose it with itself
operation I'm gonna call it cop to come
to it takes one function f and the
definition of cop to is compose F with F
and if I then apply cop to 2 square + 3
it's saying okay compose square and
square we just did that that was the
fourth power apply it to 3 I get 81 and
now we can do some weird stuff because
suppose that I apply comp 2 to cop 2 and
then apply that to add one and apply
that to 3 well that was a little hard to
follow and I'm going to let you think it
through but cop 2 of cop tow is composed
something with it four times and when
you do that with add 1 what happens
is that you're adding one four times two
three
if I come to of comp two of square I'm a
composing square with itself and then
composing that with itself I'm really
squaring four times and I wind up with
two to the fourth or sixteen is the
power that I'm taking and so composed
who have composed whose square of three
is this rather large number three to the
sixteenth it could be a little bit
tricky to think through but it all makes
perfect sense and it works just fine in
recursive programming languages that
allow this kind of untyped or
generically typed composition okay so
why is it that computer scientists are
so daring and mathematicians are so
timid about self-reference and the
reason is the mathematicians have been
traumatized by Bertrand Russell because
of Russell's famous paradox which we're
now ready to look at so um what Russell
was proposing and it's gonna look just
like a diagonal argument is Russell said
let's let W be the collection of sets s
such that s is not a member of s now
let's think about that for a little bit
most sets are not members of themselves
like the set of integers is not a member
of itself because the only thing in it
is in it are integers and the set of the
power set of the integers is not a
member of itself because every a member
of the power set of integers is a set of
integers whereas the power set of
integers is a set of sets of those
things so those familiar sets are
typically not members of themselves but
who knows maybe there are these weird
sets like the like the circular lists or
a function that can compose with itself
that is a member of itself now let me
step back for a moment and mention where
it weighted Russell yet thinking about
this and it comes from the period in the
late 19th century when
mathematicians and logicians were trying
to think about confirming and
establishing the foundations of math
what was math absolutely about what were
the fundamental objects that that
mathematics could be built from and what
were the rules for understanding those
ABS objects and it was pretty well
agreed that sets were it you could build
everything out of sets and you just need
to understand sets and then you're in
business and there was a German
mathematician named Freya who tried to
demonstrate this by developing a set
theory very carefully giving careful
axioms for what sets were and he showed
how you could build out of sets you
could build the integers and then you
could build rationals which are sort of
just pairs of integers and then you
could build real numbers by taking
collections of rationals that um that
had a least upper bound and oh and then
you can keep going and you can build
functions and continuous functions and
he showed how you could build up the
basic structures of mathematical
analysis and prove their basic theorems
in his formal set theory the problem was
that Russell came along and looked at
frege's set theory and came up with the
following paradox he defined W to be the
collection of essence sets such that s
is not a member of s Fraga would
certainly have said that's a
well-defined set and and he will
acknowledge that W as a set um and let's
look at what this means and I mean this
diagonal argument so let's remember
what's if by this definition of W but we
have is that a set s isn't W if and only
if s is not a member of s ok that's fine
then just let s be W and we immediately
get a contradiction that W is in W if
and only if W is not in W port Fraga
he's his book was a disaster math is
broken you can prove that you're the
Pope you can prove the pigs fly verified
programs crash math is just broken it's
not reliable you can prove anything by
in frege's system because it reached a
contradiction and from something false
you can prove anything
well Fraga you know had a book it was a
vanity publication and the the preface
of it had to be rewritten and he said
look my systems broken and I know that
and Russell showed that unambiguously
but I think that there's still something
here that salvageable and so I'm gonna
publish the book but I apologize for the
fact that you can't rely on the
conclusions poor Freya
that was his life work gone down the
drain okay um how do we resolve this
what's wrong with this apparent paradox
of Russell's well um the assumption was
that w-was a set and that turns out to
be what we can doubt so the definition
of W is that for all sets W s is in W if
and only if s is not in s and we got a
contradiction by saying okay um
substitute W for s but that's allowed
only if you believe that W is a set now
it looks like it ought to be because
it's certainly well defined by that
formula but it was well understood at
the time that that was the fix to the
paradox
you just can't oh wow W to be a set the
problem was it that W was acknowledged
by everybody to be absolutely clearly
defined mathematically it was this bunch
of sets and yet we're gonna say it's not
a set well it's okay that'll fix
Russell's paradox but it leaves us with
a much bigger general philosophical
question is when is a well-defined
mathematical object the set and one
isn't the set and that's what you need a
sophisticated rules for when is it that
you're going to define some collection
of elements and you can be sure it's a
set as opposed to something else called
a class by the way which is basically
something that's too big to be a set
because if it was a set it would be it
would contain itself and be circular and
self referential well there's no simple
answer to this question about what
things are sets and what are not sets
but over a time by the 1930s people had
pretty much settled on an very
economical and and persuasive set of
axioms for set theory called the Zermelo
Fraenkel set theory axiom